Hello.
>> How you doing?
>> Good. How are you?
>> I'm pretty good. Thank you for asking.
Did Did I say your name right? Is it Is
it far too?
>> Yes. Sarah.
>> Awesome. And Sarah? I'll just call you
Sarah. Is that okay?
>> Yeah. And what should I call you?
>> My name's Avery.
>> Hi, Avery.
>> Hi. So, I guess you're here to prove
that Jesus was a Muslim. Is that right?
>> Yes. And I would like to take on the
word itself. What does Muslim mean to be
a Muslim?
>> I'll go with whatever you define it as.
So our religion, Islam, comes from being
able, it says being able to submit to
the will of God and not submitting to
your own desires. Right?
>> Okay.
>> So anyone that submits to God's
commandments and the way of God is
Muslim, a follower of Islam. So for you
for this sentence to say prove Jesus was
a Muslim is pretty much asking prove
that Jesus wasn't a submitter to the
will of God.
>> Okay. So when you say a submitter to the
will of God um which God are you
particularly talking about because a lot
of people have a God that they believe
that they submit to. Right. Um, so is it
is it a particular concept of God that
you're referring to or could it be just
any god that anybody believes in?
>> I believe that there's one creator. So
for example, let's just go with Jesus.
And here you're saying prove that he was
a Muslim. Doesn't necessarily mean we
don't have to define who this god is. It
just mean being Muslim means that you're
submitting to the will of God. So
whoever you consider Jesus considered
God. If you're saying prove that he was
a Muslim, I proved it to you by telling
you that he too submitted to who he
considered God. Well, you guys consider
the father, right?
>> Okay. So, so to be clear, um I'm a
Christian and I believe that Jesus is
God. So, would you say and I submit to
Jesus? I submit to his commands and what
he taught. So, would you say that I'm a
Muslim even though I believe that Jesus
is the God I submit to? If you believe
that Jesus is God and you submit to his
will, then that would make you a Muslim.
So the term a Muslim means one that
submits to the will of God. You define
God however you see fit. In my religion,
there's one universal God, the creator
of Jesus, you and me.
>> So by you considering that Jesus is God,
that's between you and the creator of
the heavens and earth. I personally do
not believe that he was a god, but to
each his own.
>> So, so, okay, this is kind of this is a
little bit different from what I usually
hear. Uh, so you're saying that being a
Muslim, uh, it doesn't matter what who
who you say God is, it doesn't matter
who you define God as. Whatever you
believe God to be, as long as you submit
to whatever you're calling God, then
you're a Muslim. I I could submit to
Jesus and and think he's God and be a
Muslim. Cuz like if if somebody can
believe that their mother is God and
submit to their mother and be considered
a Muslim, is that right?
>> Being a Muslim means submitting to the
will of the higher power. Whichever book
you believe in, I believe in the Quran.
I believe in God, one God. So me
following that book and submitting to
his commandments and his way is what the
term Muslim Islam is defined. Not my own
desires, not what society wants me to,
you know, follow, but no, the book that
I choose, who I define as God, I submit
to his way in Arabic Muslim Islam. I got
you.
>> So if I if I believe that my if I
believe that my mother was God
>> and I submitted to my mother as my God,
then I'm a Muslim.
>> So are we defining? So these are two
different questions you're asking me,
right? You're asking me who is God now
and that is not what you are asking. You
said prove was Jesus a Muslim and I came
up to
>> Yeah. The reason why this question that
means
>> the reason why this is relevant is
because your the definition you give has
a presumption. It has a presupposition
in it. Meaning it's it has a
presupposition of who God is. So you
have to submit to this God or this
concept of God in order to qualify to be
a Muslim. That's why this is important.
Like saying saying, "Oh, just anybody
who submits to God is a Muslim." It's
not that simple. You got to define what
God you're talking about which qualifies
you to be a Muslim. It sounds like Sarah
that you're saying it doesn't matter who
you say God is or what you say God is.
You could think that God is a statute.
You could think God is a bush. You could
think God is a human. Whatever. If you
submit to whatever you think God is,
then you qualify to be a Muslim, even if
you have a false concept of of the true
God. Is that right?
>> So yes and no. And let me be very clear
here.
>> Okay.
>> So we're speaking in ter linguistically,
right, wise, like language wise, right?
Allah does not necessarily mean a single
like a a deity that's separate from what
you consider God. Allah is the name God
in Arabic, right? So in my language as a
Somali, Allah is called, right? In um
English, he's called God. Allah in
Arabic, God in Arabic is Allah. So who
do you consider to be the creator of the
heavens and the earth? And which book do
you define as his? And whichever book
commandments you follow in that way is
that makes you Muslim just means you're
submitting to the will of whoever your
god is.
>> Yeah. Okay. So that's that's where I I
have to disagree with that definition
Sarah. Um,
>> okay.
>> I I from what I've seen and when I look
at Quran and when I look at like when I
look up even the definition of like
Muslim in its in its language, it's
talking about submitting to the God
specifically that is described within
Islam and who is supposed to be the God
of Abraham, the God of Moses, the God,
you know, the God that sent these
prophets, the God that sent Muhammad.
Like that's who is supposed to who
you're supposed to recognize as God. and
then therefore you are a Muslim. And if
you don't, then you're outside of of
Islam. You're not a Muslim and you're a
disbeliever.
>> Do you believe Okay. Do you believe in
God or you believe in many gods? Can I
ask?
>> I I I believe in one God. I believe in
one God.
>> Do you believe that there's one God that
created everything including you and I?
>> Yes.
>> It doesn't matter what we consider him
to be. Each person to
>> It does.
>> Okay. You believe that? Okay. You
believe that if I call God Allah and you
call God Jesus, that I'm wrong and I'm
bound to go to hell. But you're right.
And that's what you believe.
>> The the the re Well, just to fine-tune
that a bit, I believe that God has a
true identity. Like he he has revealed
who he actually is. So he's not just
some generic uh being who has no true
identity that we can assign whatever
characteristic we want to him. He has an
actual uh identity. He revealed exactly
who he is. And so anything outside of
that would be falsehood. You know what
I'm saying? So go ahead.
>> So in the in the Bible
>> does it does Jesus say I am God? He he
he he says that in different words in
different ways. So like he claims he
claims titles that belong to like names,
attributes, titles that belong to God
alone for himself, which is the same
thing as claiming to be God. Like it's
like if I were to say I have students
and I give them lessons, what am I
claiming to be? I'm claiming to be a
teacher, right? Without saying I'm a
teacher. So Jesus does does the same
thing. He says like he's the first and
the last. He says he's the giver of
eternal life. He says he's the source of
peace and all these, you know, he's the
judge of he's the judge of the universe.
He makes these type of claims claiming
to be God.
>> So, but does he say does Jesus say that
he prays to the father?
>> Of course. Yeah. Because there's a
trinity.
>> So, who explain that to me a little
more.
>> So, uh the concept of God in the Bible
that we see is that you'll see that
there's the the one God, the one
infinite being exists as three distinct
persons. So there's the father, the son,
Jesus and the holy spirit who all share
the same nature as the one god while so
that's why you can see the father and
the son communicate and interact with
each other and when the son takes on
flesh takes on a human form walks
amongst us on earth we see what that
communication looks like when Jesus
prays to the father um the father also
speaks and uh uh communicates with the
son and vice versa so there's a mutual
ual glorification. The son glorifies the
father. The father glorifies the son
mutually. So, okay, I don't think I
follow and please excuse my ignorance
and I in no way do I mean disrespect,
but um so in essence you believe that
God is three and he when he's on earth
he's Jesus but when he's in heaven
>> I believe that God is there's one divine
essence one divine being who has
revealed himself as three distinct
persons. So being and personhood are two
different things. When I'm saying being
is what you are, what makes you you.
What what are the qualifies that make
like you what you are, you are a human
being, right? What God is, he is a
divine being, the divine being. There's
only one of those, right? As with you as
a human being, you only consist of one
person. You're one human being and one
human person. For God, he's one divine
being and three divine persons that
share that same divine being. Father,
son, and spirit. So that's that's what
we see with the interaction with the
father, the son, Jesus, the spirit.
That's what we see throughout the
scripture. That's why Jesus, for
example, Jesus says, "Go out and
baptize, make disciples of all nations,
baptizing them in the name, one name,
name singular, of the father, the son,
and the holy spirit." That's what Jesus
says. So he even like highlights the
three persons sharing even one name or
one essence. And this is in the book of
King James.
>> No, no, King James doesn't have a book.
That's just a English translation, but
uh it's in the it's in the Gospel.
You'll find this in Matthew.
>> Which one? Oh, it's in Matthew. Okay. Um
King James translated it from where?
Where was the Bible translated from?
>> The it's it's originally, if you're
talking about the the Gospel, the Gospel
was originally written in Greek and then
uh translated into many different
languages, one of them English. So it
was written in Greek and Greece, but
Jesus is from Bethlehem.
>> Yeah. Which was under Roman occupation,
which means that the common tongue was
Greek
>> and not America.
>> Not Aramaic. No, it's one of them. He
was multilingual. But the main the main
language was co Greek.
>> So if God himself came down as a divine
being in the form of a flesh, why does
he need to pray to something outside of
him? It's not that there is a need to
he's not praying out something outside
of him. He's he's communicating with the
father. Something that
>> that has always happened eternally. No,
remember I said there's three there's
three distinct persons. So they're not
the same person.
>> There are three distinct persons that
are unified in essence. So they can
communicate with each other. No problem.
>> Why doesn't he pray to the spirit? Why
the father alone?
>> Well, the spirit is in him. So with how
this functions, you have the Holy Spirit
came dwells dwells in Jesus and it's in
the spirit that he prays to the father.
How the mode and how that exactly works,
I can't tell you. I can just only tell
you what the scripture says. So
>> well, how can you believe in something
that you don't even fully understand
yourself?
>> Well, you don't fully understand Allah
and his attributes, but you still
believe it.
>> Oh, no. I understand 100% of what I
believe in.
>> You sure?
>> I'm 1,000%.
>> Okay. So, if I Okay, so I'll ask you
then. Um, it says that Allah has hands
that he made Adam with his own hands.
You believe Allah has hands?
>> Absolutely.
>> What are his hands like?
>> I mean, if it's concealed, I mean, he
defined it. He has hands. How I mean, if
I can't physically see him, then I would
assume that his hands would look like
mine. But then the Quran says that
there's nothing comparable to Allah. So
how could his hands look like that?
>> But that does that define his hands?
>> Not necessarily.
>> Why not? Why doesn't that uh statement
refer to his power? And why does it why
do you automatically go there?
>> Well, because this is Adam was made
uniquely uh uniquely different than
anything else. It's he made everything
else by the word of his power or
something like that being and it is. But
with Adam specifically, he made it with
his own hands. He says, which
>> flesh?
>> Yes. From from the clay and the dust. So
we see that he he actually has hands.
What is that like? Or or do you take it
figurative? Do you take it as literal
hands or do you take it figurative for
his power?
>> I believe I take it as just like there's
seven levels of heaven and beyond. Um I
believe that God is not we're not we
don't have the intellect to define who
he is or what he
>> say that again.
>> We want we don't have the intellect to
define him.
>> So we don't have the
>> necessarily mean that we don't have the
intellect to understand or believe in
him but we don't have the intellect to
define who he is.
>> Meaning that he's far above what we
could ever
>> imagine. Right.
>> Imagine. But here you're saying that
>> you said something important.
>> Okay, go ahead.
>> We don't have the intellect to define
who and what he is. That's beyond us.
It's beyond he's beyond what we could
imagine. So our finite minds cannot
define intricately what God is. We only
can know what has been revealed to us
and take that. But there's things about
God that go beyond our intellect and our
understanding. Right.
>> Right. And that is the same way that you
cannot say that Islam is incorrect or
Judaism is correct or just you your
religion is correct.
>> Then you have to in my book it says that
he is the one that descended upon us the
Torah, the Inil and the Quran. And the
reason for the Torah is the individuals
hiding it to fulfill their own desires.
The injeil is the deception that it was
translated into. And finally, one
recitation that could never be
mistransated.
>> Okay. So, a lot was said. So, I want to
I want to before moving on to the what
we can say is wrong, I just want to make
sure we hammer this point that you agree
that there's things about God in your
belief that you can't fully comprehend.
You you don't have the intellect. We as
humans, not just you, but we as humans
do not have the intellect to fully
understand.
>> His power,
>> his power is what I can't to understand.
>> Of course, but you but yet you still
believe that he is all he has all that
power, right?
>> Absolutely. You and I are communicating
by his will and we're thousands of miles
away from one another. So
>> So that's my point, sister. My point is
is that I just like how you um accept
that you know there are things about God
that you cannot fully understand but you
accept them anyway. You still believe in
them even though you can't fully
understand it in the same way.
>> I I'm being called into the surgery and
>> I have to go. I haven't been called into
surgery yet. Have a good day.
>> You too. You too. Hopefully we can talk
again soon. I hope her I hope the
surgery goes well. All right, guys.
Well, we got from the sister that uh you
can believe anything is God and be a
Muslim. I wonder if the other Muslims
agree with that word. Was that uh did
that almost get a shahad out of you?
>> Oh, man. I was over here saying a shu
man.
>> How y'all guys doing
up?
>> Everybody's Muslim.
>> Everybody's Muslim. What's up, man?
>> What's good? What's good?
>> What's up, man? You here to win that
2200?
>> Yeah, man.
>> All right.
>> Deceit. But listen, first of all, do you
even know what the word Muslim even
means? Like honestly, do you know?
>> Well, from the last guest, the lady told
me uh that a Muslim means one who
submits to uh any higher power that you
believe is God and you submit to that
and you're Muslim.
>> One who submits to God. One who submits
to God.
>> Well, she said to any God that you
think.
>> And no way she said that.
>> She did.
>> God.
>> Yeah, she said whatever I think is God.
>> Wait, wait. Okay. So my brother, I could
worship Satan and call myself a Muslim.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Basically,
>> that's hilarious, man. That's hilarious.
There's no way.
>> B. That's basically what she what she's
saying, man.
>> But listen, okay, so I'm going to tell
you real quick. Like Muslim, it comes
from the Arabic language, right? So the
word Muslim means one who submits to
God. And then you can even find it in
the Hebrew language, too. They call it
musham.
>> It has different from Muslim.
>> It has the same root meaning, bro.
Listen,
>> it it has it has the same root, but the
root the root they don't even have the
same meaning. Mushala means to be
perfect and complete.
>> No problem. But I explained the word to
you, right? So one who submits to God.
>> Okay. So did Jesus ever submit his will
to God?
>> Well, but we got to talk about your
definition first. Okay.
>> I already explained to you the one who
submits to God.
>> Well, that's and that's how she started
off too. And then I asked her my
follow-up question which then led her to
be to say that whatever you consider God
to be and whatever you consider the
higher power to be is what you submit to
and therefore you're a Muslim. So
>> bro I clarified it right now bro. Listen
you
>> you just said you just said you just
said God
>> you can't worship Bal God. Exactly. The
one true God the God of Abraham, Moses
and Jesus. When I say God for example I
mean the true God bro.
>> Okay.
>> You understand? Like
>> All right. All right. So, give me give
me give me some like give me some like
intricate
>> details about who this who this god is
like what what makes him stand out that
makes him the true god.
>> He's the creator of the heavens and
earth.
>> A lot of people believe that about their
gods. Give me something unique.
>> Allah
he created the heavens and the earth.
And there's only one being that done
that and that's the god. Right. I
>> Okay. So, let's say I believe in uh I I
believe in God. I believe in the God
that I believe in is the creator of the
heavens and the earth. Is the only being
who created the heavens and the earth.
Right.
>> But the God but the God that but the God
that I'm referring to is a statute in my
backyard. Am I a Muslim?
>> No problem. That No, of course not. Cuz
that's your opinion. But I just told you
what the meaning Muslim means and what
we see it as.
>> It's too generic, bro. It's too generic.
You're missing my point. It's too
generic. You didn't You didn't give me
who your God is. Cuz every everybody
says that their God is the one who
created the heaven and the earth.
Everybody says that. Who is your God?
Like who is he specifically? Who is this
one?
>> The God of Abraham.
>> All right. So, let me let me like help
out. So, um the the true God that you're
talking about, is he uh is he a trinity?
>> No, of course not.
>> Okay. Um does he have any children in
any sense?
>> No. But wait, did Jesus ever call his
God a trinity? No, he didn't. He didn't
say his trinity.
>> All right, guys. All right. All right.
All right. So, he's not a trinity. He
has no children in any sense. Um,
I think that's good enough. We can go
with that. Okay. So, show me that. Can
you show me that Jesus believed and
submitted to this God that you're
talking about who is not a trinity and
didn't have any children in any sense?
>> No problem. In in Islam and according to
Sharia customs, we have something called
the six articles of faith, right? Uh, I
think you heard of them. So, the show of
faith. Can you show me that G? You don't
have to you don't have to say them all.
I know. I know them. I just need you to
show me where Jesus believed in this
concept of God that you just told me
about who's not a trinity and who is not
a
>> I can show a father. We already
established which God I'm talking about,
right? First of all,
>> and I already have
>> Okay,
>> so now so now show me that Jesus believe
in that God you're talking about.
>> Well, that wasn't the question though.
The question is to prove he's a Muslim.
>> Yes. So that means that to for Jesus to
be a Muslim, he has to believe and
submit to the God you're talking about,
right? Or else he's not a Muslim, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So he has to You got to show me
that. Show me that he believes in the
God you're talking about who's not a
trinity.
>> Okay.
>> Who's not a father in any sense.
>> The Bible.
>> Exactly.
>> But I know I don't know I don't know the
Bible by heart, but I know there's some
verses where literally calls out upon
the God of Moses. Right.
>> Well, give give some verses. I mean, if
you if you want to use the if you want
to use the internet real quick, that's
fine. You know, whatever helps, bro.
There's no shame in in checking it out
real quick. You you want some time to
look it up real quick?
>> Yeah. I'm going to look it up. One
second. If I leave the chat, this
because I left the screen. One second.
>> I got you. While he's doing that, I'm
going to go ahead and uh read a couple
of super chats. So, you didn't have to
drop. You didn't have to drop, man. What
was it? Oh, his name was Umar bin Katab.
So guys, moderators, if you guys see
Umar Katab request up again, go ahead
and let him up. How you doing?
>> Salam.
What Jesus said himself.
>> Oh yeah.
>> Okay. Listen. Um, do you know how Jesus
greeted people? How did he greet people?
>> Yeah.
>> How did he do it?
>> How did he You told me what? I I don't
know, bro. I thought you were going
Okay.
>> I thought you were a Christian.
>> Okay. Can I just read you how he greeted
people?
>> All right. Go on.
>> All right. So, we're going to go to the
Bible. We going to get this Bible.
>> We're going to get the Bible. And where
I'mma take you, my brother, I'm going to
take you and and listen at the Bible.
I'm going to take you to to John to John
14. I'm going to show you how Jesus
greeted people.
>> All right. Go ahead.
>> You ready for this?
>> I'm going watch this. John 14 verse 27.
He says,
>> "Okay,
>> peace I leave with you. My peace I give
to you. Not as the world gives do I give
to you. Let not your hearts be troubled,
neither let them be afraid. That's how
Jesus greets them. So he says,
>> "Is that the truth?"
>> My peace. Is that the truth?
>> Okay, but that was Okay,
>> you're cutting out.
>> Yeah, but that was that was a little
quote he just gave him that one time.
>> Is that Is that the truth?
>> He said, "Peace be upon you."
>> No. Is that the truth?
>> What?
>> Is that the truth? What I just read? Is
that the truth?
>> That is the truth. Maybe. Yeah, but that
was that was just that one time. Okay,
probably you just gave like a quote for
that one time. But yo,
>> on a regular, how did he treat how did
>> this is on the regular?
>> You say this is on the regular.
I leave with you. Show me where Jesus
said that on the regular. Show me show
me two times where Jesus saidalamikum.
>> Okay.
>> So Jesus was speaking Arabic.
>> He was speaking Arabic.
>> Did he just leave?
>> Yes, he left, guys.
>> All right. All right. I'm out.
>> Oh, man. All right. Well, let's try
somebody else, man. Let's try somebody
else.
>> He know he lied.